welcome back we have a big announcement
to make by popular demand the five is
returning to its original time slot 5:00
p.m. Eastern Time yes your wishes are
granted America while we've greatly
enjoyed connecting with our audience
during primetime we're also very excited
to go back to the five o'clock hour
after all it's our favorite number
so the lots of things happening here
because not only do we go back to five
then Henry comes in at 9:00 and there
laura ingraham is gonna join the Laura I
think it's the Ingram angle at 10:00 I
think it's like it going and going back
to the original right because we this is
our show five o'clock five people five
pm boom boom boom five days a week
exactly shots of tequila not exactly and
he goes okay besides that then Hannity's
going back to nine where when I first
joined Fox and as all of us say Hannity
was at 9 o'clock every night so he's
going back where he used to be when he
was Hannity and what it was Hannity and
calm so there's something kind of nice
and vintage about that and they can go
home again you can and all the fans like
it all the time when I see people are
very passionate about like and now I
can't watch you come on but I what I
want to say is for those of you that
like you know experienced us in
part-time at 9:00 o'clock if you could
come to head though because we're even
funnier at 5:00 oh my gosh we're very
high energy at 5:00 my bedtime so
usually when that guy in the gym who
puts his bottles down and claims every
station he is watching the five isn't
that right yeah it's true you know the
great thing about this is I will finally
lose the weight that I gained doing this
show at nine o'clock and eating it 11
o'clock at night.i but thank you left at
the other part is that we're also gonna
be on a 5 a.m. we're doing a live show
we're doing five and five no I'm not
joking I want they told me to hold to
keep this news from you guys until now
so we're gonna do a 5 a.m. morning show
and then we come back we do 5 p.m. and
that's called Fox and Friends first not
anymore oh I should have told them you
know what they're probably asleep right
now they have no idea but Laura does a
connor until the end of october Jesse
and so they're gonna have people
standing in in the 10 o'clock hour what
do you think of this I guess they're
gonna do a great job keeping that seat
warm for Laura she's gonna do a fence
how does it do it next week so I meant
love you to show up attend in order to
do I'm not available that day and I'm
not going back to five because I was
never at five so this is going to be fun
a new experience I just got you about
what I'm gonna eat and when I'm gonna
eat it because it's gonna change my
entire eating schedule what's so funny
very good for you Jess you think so I
write happy hour in our starts at six
o'clock instead of ten o'clock much
better line up okay good change my cook
my commute used to be so much easier to
go home at ten o'clock there's nobody on
the roads and go as fast as I want no
one sees what I do take the subway now
got phone that way well I think our
competitors are worried though because
we've been doing pretty well in the nine
o'clock hour I think but in the in the
five o'clock hour yeah we'll be the
number one yeah the best show on
television uh mine at five o'clock in
awe of cable sure yep Oh
so lately